خطط موسكو الذكية يقابلها دعم
امريكا لاوكرانيا ومحاولة واشنطن
واي بي جي الارهابي حتى لا نفسد
علاقتنا مع تركيا. يا لهذا الخوف
كانت بوسط بنك لبناني. السويد
تعلنها. سننأى بانفسنا عن بي كي
خلال ذلك اعلنت القوات الجوية
التابعة للحرس الثوري الايراني
الاسرائيلي يبدو ان البحرين
تتقرب من الكيان الاسرائيلي
المؤلمة. الطريقة التي يحاول بها
اعداء ايران اثارة القلقلة
ذلك بانه سيكون مشكلة على المدى
القريب فكيف يحذر الصينيون روسيا
انها ستعمق تعاونها مع روسيا على
جميع المستويات. فهل هي مسرحية
اجتماعه بالمستشار الالماني فقد
حذر موسكو من التهديدات النووية
في خدمة سلاح الجو الصيني. هي
مقاتلة من الجيل الخامس مزودة
قدرتها على المناورة والتخفي.
فهل تنجح الصين باسلحتها الجوية
الشبحية. اقوى ما تمتلكه الصين
حتى من الطائرات القتالية مصممة
تتلافى الوضع وتطلب عقد جلسة
لمجلس الامن لبحث هذا الملف فهي
ينذر بحرب وشيكة بين الكوريتين.
كما في الماضي الولايات المتحدة
التوتر في الجزيرة الكورية سجال
ميداني وكلامي وتبادل للاتهامات.
ليعلن الجيش الكوري الجنوبي نشر
ثمانين مقاتلة شبح بعضها من طراز
هي امريكا تتهم الصين وروسيا
بحماية كوريا الشمالية من
لوقف كوريا الشمالية تجاربها
الصاروخية لكن في الوقت ذاته ها
الطاقة للمحطات النووية مع دولة
عربية اخرى حيث بدأت موسكو بكسب
كرسيا على الشرفة ليستمتع ويشاهد
صواريخه وباربعة صواريخ باليستية
اوكرانيا حسب تصريح وزير
الخارجية الايراني. رد زلينسكي
وسط كييف ليؤكد ان الدعم
الامريكي لاوكرانيا سيظل ثابتا
هو الرئيس الروسي يوقع قانونا
جديدا بتجنيد مرتكبي الجرائم
من خرسون حقا? فبعد تجنيد
ثلاثمائة وثمانية عشر الفا. ها
خطة موسكو الغامضة. ذكاء موسكو
يربك الغرب والاوكران فلا احد
خالية وموحشة وقوات كييف بينما
نشرت وسائل اعلام اوكرانية
الاسرائيلي بينما تنسحب الكويت
وعمان فما الذي يحدث ايها العرب.
روسيا على غير العادة. فهل هي
مسرحية سياسية جديدة? بينما بكين
اختفاء غامض لقوات روسيا في
خرسون. وموسكو ترسل جيشا اخر نحو
عن خطة تكسب البلاد ثمانية عشر
مليار دولار كل سنة وتوفر مائة
ويا للمصالح. فبالامس لن يكونوا
ارهابيين. الحكومة المصرية تعلن
الجزائر تستبعد فرنسا من التواجد
على اموالها. الشركات الكويتية
بالوقود صل؟ الاحداث والتطورات.
باللغتين العربية والانجليز فقط.
عن اطلاق ناجح لصاروخ قائم مائة
الحامل للاقمار الصناعية والعامل
الذي قال انه سيحرر ايران قائلا
بان تحررت منذ ثلاثة واربعين
العسكرية في بلدان العالم باسم
الديموقراطية اسفرت عن الاف
يعرف في ايران بيوم الطالب. يخرج
الرئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي
تطوير اسلحتها النووية اسرع
بكثير من الولايات المتحدة ووصفت
لاداء مهمات قتالية حتى في
البيئات الصعبة. فهي اليوم تدخل
وول ستريت جورنال. تحذير غريب من
الرئيس الصيني بعد ان اعلنت بكين
اف خمسة وثلاثين ايه على طول
الحدود بين البلدين ردا على
الى دخان الحرب اسراب من
الطائرات العسكرية تحلق في سماء
الف وظيفة جديدة عن طريق
الاعتماد على الطاقة المتجددة.
بعد وقت قصير ليرد على اعلان
واشنطن انضمام قاذفة استراتيجية
المزيد من الود في للشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا. موسكو وبغداد
تقترب. الامر زاد عن حده وواشنطن
تستشيط غضبا بينما يضع كيم جونغ
تستعدان لتوقيع مذكرة تعاون في
التطبيقات المتعلقة بطاقة
نار خلال برنامج تليفزيوني
والجيش يتدخل. اظن ان المقابلة
عاما باشارة الى الثورة
الايرانية فهل وصلت رسالة رئيسي
والعمانية تنسحب من معرض بحريني
والسبب مشاركة شركات للكيان
رئيسي على ان بلاده لن تخضع
للغرب. واضاف ان تدخلات واشنطن
استراتيجية الولايات المتحدة
واعداء الثورة حسب تعبيره. وشدد
قائلا ان من يساهم فيما وصفه
باعمال الشغب في ايران ينفذ
تظاهرات حاشدة في طهران وفي ذكرى
اقتحام السفارة الامريكية او ما
النووي السلمي مع الجزائر روسيا
تعلن عن توقيع اتفاقية في مجال
ايران تكذب بقولها انها ارسلت
عددا محدودا من المسيرات لروسيا
في التفوق على امريكا. اما
الرئيس الصيني شي جين بينغ وبعد
تطمح بحليف جديد لتخرج هنا
واشنطن مصرحة ان الصين تعمل على
سياسية اعدادها وترتيب مشاهدها
بين موسكو وبكين ام ان الصين
باحدث تقنيات التكنولوجيا
والذكاء الاصطناعي والتي ترفع من
العسكرية. البنتاجون يعلن عن
مساعدات عسكرية جديدة لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا بدبة وعتاد عسكري ثقيل
بقيمة مائة وتسعة عشر مليون
تحتاجون لها يا هؤلاء ومن حرب
التصريحات الى حرب المساعدات
متناسية اشقائها الفلسطينيين. يا
للعجب! مشاجرات واشتباكات واطلاق
مقاطعة سونجان الغربية وفق صحيفة
واشنطن بوست الامريكية. ومن
على الجرح الصيني. خمسون دولة
حول العالم تطالب الصين باتخاذ
الخطوات اللازمة للافراج عن جميع
المحرومين من حريته تعسفيا في
والمشاكل في طهران هي الطريقة
التي رد بها الايرانيون اليوم مع
القتلى والجرحى ليذهب الرئيس
الايراني نحو الرد على بايدن
من شيء تعمل بكين على تطوير
ايران تحتفل بذكرى واشنطن
انه في عام الفين وثمانية عشر
كانت قد وقعت موسكو والرياض على
ويعلنها. ندين بشدة اطلاق كوريا
الشمالية الصواريخ ونعتبره
قصيرة المدى المجنون يطلقها
باتجاه الجارة الجنوبية جاء ذلك
دولة. حرب امريكا الباردة ضد
الصين لا تمر عبر التصريحات
اطلاق الجارة الشمالية مائة
وثمانين طائرة حربية في تطور
تصعيدا كبيرا وانتهاكا لقرارات
مجلس الامن. ومن حرب التصريحات
المنطقة المحظورة بين الكوريتين
وشهدت الساعات الاخيرة ارتفاع
في اوكرانيا وذلك في خروج نادر
عن دعمه لمواقف موسكو بحسب صحيفة
الجرائم المحتملة الى المجرم
الذي تصنعه بكين. التنين الجبار.
كيم هنا تلجأ واشنطن الى بكين
وموسكو لاستخدام نفوذهما للضغط
العقوبات. فما كل هذا يا ابناء
العم سام ليعود الاتحاد الاوروبي
والتهديدات فقط. هنا يضغط
الامريكان بطريقة اخرى وينثرون
ليست في وضع يسمح لها بدعم حربين
في وقت واحد. الصين تواجه خمسين
خارطة طريق في مجال الطاقة
النووية السلمية. الحرب الكورية
الاتفاقيات? ولماذا يتقرب بوتين
من العرب بشكل متسارع? ولا ننسى
يجيب قائلا. نواجه صعوبة في
امداد اوكرانيا بصواريخ جافلين
انذار. ها هو مستشار الامن
القومي الامريكي جيكس سوليفان من
السلمية للتقنيات النووية. فما
هو الهدف يا ترى من هذه
ليس واضحا ان يخلون المدينة ام
انهم ينصبون فخا للاوكرانيين
مسيرات الى روسيا ولكن قبل الحرب
ولم تكن مخصصة للاستخدام في حرب
للمناورات المشتركة مع كوريا
الجنوبية. يا لقلبك القوي. يا
الغربية الى المجاملات العسكرية.
ها هي طهران تعترف اخيرا بارسال
لتستمر حرب الاتهامات. وبين هذا
وذاك وبعد اتفاقية التعاون
بقيمة اربعمائة مليون دولار
تتضمن دبابات وصواريخ ومسيرات
لعدم توفر اشباه المواصلات? اذا
فلماذا تمنعون الرقائق وانتم
مستثنيا بعض الجرائم التي لا
تغتفر في العقيدة الروسية
اوكرانيا. مشيرا الى انه ستتم
مساعدة كل اللاجئين القادمين من
حزب بايدن الديموقراطي? هل
سيتوقف دعم اوكرانيا? جو بايدن
دولار فكيف سترد موسكو على هذا
الدعم السخي? ومن المساعدات
يستطيع ان يفرق بين الانسحاب
والكمين يا سادة. هنا اجواء
تقارير تفيد باختفاء غامض للقوات
الروسية والموالين لها من شوارع
لتدخل هولندا في خط المساعدات
العسكرية وتكشف عن توجهها لتزويد
وقويا بعد انتخابات التجديد
النصفي للكونجرس لكن ماذا ان خسر
تسهيل اجراءات منح الجنسية
الروسية للاجئين القادمين من
خركيف او من اي منطقة اوكرانية
فعن اي انسحاب نتحدث وبدون سابق
كالمدانين بالخيانة. ليس ذلك
فحسب. هنا بوتين يتحدث. نعمل على
تستعرض بالتنين الجبار. والجزائر
توجه ضربة موجعة لفرنسا. فيما
تعلن مصر عن خطة ستدر عليها
مليارات الدولارات. وايران تطلق
فالاجواء الاستخباراتية ضبابية
الى هذه اللحظة. هل انسحب بوتين
خرسون. ونقلت عن سكان المدينة ان
الجنود الروس والدوريات وحواجز
معظم السكان المدنيين والسلطات
الامنية الاوكرانية تحذر من انه
التفتيش كلها اصبحت فجأة نادرة
في وسط المدينة. في حين غادرها
دولة تجتمع لتطالب الصين بهذا
الطلب. والزعيم الصيني يوبخ
يحضره الزعيم الكوري وواشنطن
تستنجد ببكين وموسكو. وخمسون
رسائل عسكرية خطيرة لامريكا
والبحرين تستضيف شركات للكيان
لاوكرانيا وهولندا تدخل خط
المساعدات العسكرية لكييف. فكيف
اوكرانيا. فما الذي يجري وواشنطن
ايضا ترسل مساعدات عسكرية جديدة
تأليب الغرب ضد موسكو. فلمن
ستكون الغلبة?
سترد موسكو وبين الكوريتين كل
شيء يشير الى الحرب. فما الذي